my name is mathias and i am the
founder of datatec this video
is about the confidence interval in the test
and with that we start
right away to repeat what is the
confidence interval
when you calculate a perpetrator in addition to the
statistics programs such as the e type 1
confidence interval  But what is the
confidence interval? The
confidence interval gives you an
area in which a core value will lie with a
certain probability.
Often, the probability is set at 95
percent. Then the
confidence interval gives you the area in which
the value is 95 percent. A perpetrator
compares the mean  Differences, for
example, you can check with an offender
whether there is a difference in salary
between men and women.
First of all
, you have a group of men and you have a group of women. The
group of men has a certain
average salary. The group of
women has one  certain mean
value in salary and  you want to know now is
there a difference between the
mean
values ​​but you actually want to make a statement
as to whether there is
a difference in salary in the population
so you have a population let's
say of all employed men
and women in Germany in the
population that an average value  of the
salary for men and an
average value for the salary of women and you
want to know is there a
difference in the average values
he didn't have to survey the entire
population can
you use a sample so you
take a sample of men and
a sample of women
in this sample  there is a
high probability of a difference
in salary,
but there is a high probability that this difference will
not be the
same as this so that
you can roughly estimate the range in which
the mean difference in the
population lies. dudas calculates the confidence
interval that  conference in the
ball he then indicates an area in
which there is a certain
probability of the mean value
difference in the population
so you can say, for example,
95 percent of the mean value
difference between men and women in the population is
between minus 99 and 1000 euros
how do you calculate the conference in
the case that the confidence interval can be calculated
with ex dash plusminus t x it by the
root of n just
down stands for the upper
limit with plus one for the lower
limit with minus i dash is the
mean difference
is the tee  is for the respective
confidence level
is the sample size
and it is the standard
deviation and ebrd you can now read from a table of
course you can
also simply use a statistical software web for the
calculation and then you will get a
result part of the continent interval of
the difference depending on  the
object same varia  nz or unequal
variance we can then read the
result from it either in this series or in
this series let's just assume the
same variance then
in this case the result would be that
we have a mean value difference of - 650
euros and we have a lower one  limit
of -
1399 and an upper limit of 99 euros
i.e. the mean value difference in the
sample at - 650 to 95 percent
we can be sure that there is
a mean value
difference between - 1399 and 99
euros in the total population we will
want to check the zero hypothesis  that there is no
difference in the healed between men
and women then in
this case we would keep the new
hypothesis because the 0 is included in the 95 percent
confidence interval of the difference
, so no difference
means we have zero euros
salary difference the zero euros
are within this
interval accordingly, we can
not reject the null hypothesis,
e.g  u 95 percent is in the population of
the middle of march
difference between -
1390 and 99
if you want to calculate the competence interval with data
then simply visit
date up de and copy your data in
this table then click on
this cup and choose the income and
the gender  from or the variables with
which you want to calculate a perpetrator is
here we can see right away that
a test for independent samples was
calculated if you now scroll down
gives you the results from
the deb gives you the descriptive
statistics that's a box  will that
be in vienna test of variance equality
to determine whether variance
equality is present or not and
down here you will get the values ​​for the
care value and for the
confidence interval it's quite easy just
try it out
so i hope he has the video  please
see you next time bye